hey what's up guys my name is the Cherno
welcome to another episode of my people
are plus theory so today we're going to
learn all about house people as plus
works we're going to kind of try and
keep it simple for now but we're going
to learn about how we go from the source
file the actual text file to an actual
executable binary or program that we can
run the basic workflow of writing a
simple sub program is you have a series
of source files which you write actual
text ins and then you pass it through a
compiler which compiles it into some
kind of binary now that binary can be
some sort of library or it can be an
actual executable program today we're
going to talk specifically about
executable programs or executable binary
so let's hop on over to visual studio
and check it out ok so here we have our
hello world application that we wrote in
the previous video when we learn how to
set up C++ on Windows it's a pretty
basic program but there are quite a
number of things going on here first of
all we have this include iostream
statement now this is something called a
preprocessor statement anything that
begins with a hash is a preprocessor
statement the first thing that a
compiler does when it receives a source
file is it pre processes all of your
preprocessor statement that's why they
called preprocessor statements because
they happen just before the actual
compilation in this case is something
called include what include will do is
find a file so in this case we're
looking for a file called iostream take
all of the contents of that file and
just paste it into this current file
these files that you include are
typically called header files and we'll
discuss them more in depth as the series
goes on the reason we are including
something called iostream is because we
need a declaration for a function called
C out which lets us scream stuff to our
console next we have this main function
now the main function is very important
because every simplest program has
something like this the main function is
called the entry point it's the entry
point for our application that means
that when we run our application our
computer starts executing code that
begins in this function as the program
is running our computer will execute the
lines of code that we type in order of
course there are certain things that can
break or change the order of execution
and those are primarily called control
flow statements or calls to other
functions but the gist is that our code
gets executed line by line so the first
thing that will get executed in our
application will be this hello world the
hour
and then the next thing is this the end
gate function and then since that's all
that we've got inside our main function
our program will terminate now for those
of you who are familiar with functions
you might notice that the return types
of main is actually int however we're
not returning an integer that's because
the main function is actually a special
case you don't have to return any kind
of value from the main function if you
don't return anything it will assume
that your returning is zero this only
applies to the main function there is a
special case all right so let's talk a
little bit more about what this is
actually doing this kind of syntax might
look strange for someone who's new to
C++ and it is a little bit unfortunate
that it's actually written this way
because it doesn't make too much sense
when you first look at it but basically
these left angular brackets which look
kind of like a bit shift left operator
are actually just an overloaded operator
so you need to think of them as a
function now I know they look like an
operator but here's the thing operators
are just functions so in this case this
would actually be the same thing as if
it was something like the out of print
and then hello world is our parameter
and then maybe we would follow it on
along with another print that's all it
is you have to think of these operators
as functions and if you think of them
that way then it makes a little bit more
sense so what we're actually doing here
is we're pushing this hollow world
string into this CR which basically
causes it to get printed to the console
and then we're pushing an end line this
end line basically just tells our
console to advance to the next line the
scenes of get function in our case will
basically just wait until we press ENTER
before advancing to our next line of
code which is nothing so basically what
I'm saying is our programs execution
will pause on this line until we press
ENTER because this function is just
going to wait for us to press ENTER and
then we advance the next line which is
nothing which means that we actually
return zero meaning our program executed
successfully and that's it that is our
entire program okay so that's our source
file we've actually got a file called
main dot CPP which is a source file how
do we get from this text to an actual
executable binary file so basically we
go through a few stages first we have
this include iostream this is something
called a preprocessor statement so this
preprocessor statement gets evaluated
before we compile the file in this case
what it does is it include
all of the content of the iostream file
into this file and I mean literally it
just it copies and pastes that file into
this file and again as I said we will
talk about how to files in more depth in
the future so don't worry too much if
you don't understand this so now all you
need to know is we include this file so
we can use to see out and see in
functions once our preprocessor
statements have been evaluated our file
gets compiled this is a stage where our
compiler transforms all of this C++ code
into actual machine code there are
several important settings that
determine how this actually happens so
let's take a brief look at them in
visual studio we have these two
important drop-down menus up here once
called a solution configuration and once
called a solution platform by default it
will probably be set to debug and then
either x86 or win32 they're actually the
same if we drop down the debug you'll
see that we've got two options debug and
release these two options are defaults
for any new project in Visual Studio and
then under solution platform you'll see
we've got x64 and x86 as our two options
again these are just default a
configuration is simply a set of rules
which applies to the building of a
project whereas the solution platform is
what platform we're targeting with our
current compilation so a good examples
that will be x86 is targeting windows
32-bit which means that we will generate
a 32-bit application for Windows for
more complicated projects where you
might be targeting different platforms
you might have Android as a platform in
that drop-down and then if you wanted to
build and deploy and debug on Android
you would change your platform to be
Android and the solution configuration
is a set of rules that defines the
compilation for that platform so let's
take a look at some of the rules that we
can change in our project let's
right-click on it and hit properties so
here we have Visual Studio as property
pages these define the rules that are
used to build them in configurations and
platforms the first thing that you need
to notice is this configuration and
platform area make sure that your
configuration and your platform is set
to the one that you actually want to
modify for some reason sometimes it
might be set to release however you're
clearly building debug which means that
none of these changes will
like to your current configuration and
if you missed that you might be
wondering why nothing's working I've had
that happen a few times it's kind of
annoying so we've got our debug
configuration you can see we've got wind
32 now wind 32 is exactly the same as
x86 okay they are the same they've got
different names for some reasons but
they are the same here we've got some
general information about our SDK
version output directory or intermediate
directory and stuff like that the
important thing to note here is that our
configuration type is set to application
if we wanted it to be a library we're
good we could change it here but it's
basically the binary there's a
compatible output since we're going for
an executable binary we'll leave it set
to application Exe the compiler settings
are located under CC + block we've got
important settings here such as include
directories optimization settings that
we may want to use cogeneration settings
preprocessor definitions and a whole lot
of stuff that we're not even going to
touch anytime soon the default little
studio configuration is actually pretty
good so we don't really have to do
anything but these are the rules that
govern how our files will get compiled
you can see the difference between the
debug and the released configuration
pretty well if you go into the
optimization tab under optimization if I
change this to release you'll see that
the optimization is set to maximize B
whereas in debug it's set to disabled
that's a great example of why I debug
mode by default is slower a lot slower
than release mode because optimization
is turned off but of course turning off
optimization will help us to debug our
code as we will later discover if you
want to learn more about how the
compiler works I've made a dedicated
video in depth covering exactly how all
of that happens so go check that out if
you're interested the link will be in
the description below each CPP file in
our project gets compiled header files
do not get compiled at all just CPP file
remember header files get included via a
preprocessor statement called include
into a CPP file and that's when they get
compiled so we've got a bunch of CPP
files that we've compiled and they
actually get compiled individually every
CPP file will get compiled into
something called an object file the
extension for that using visual studios
compiler is obj once we have all of
those individual obj files which are the
result of compiling our CPP files we
need some way to stitch them together
into one
an exe file and that's where our friend
the linker comes in you can see the
linker settings under this linker tab
but basically what the linker does is it
takes all of those obj files and it
glues them together so the linkers job
is to take all of our obj files and
stitch them together into one exe file
of course the way that it does that is
actually kind of complicated so I've
made a specific video covering that go
ahead and check that out the link will
be in the description below so let's
take a look at this in action
the first thing I want to do is actually
just compile this CPP file in Visual
Studio you can compile files
individually by hitting ctrl f7 you can
see our output here shows that we're
actually building this main del CPP file
and that it succeeded if you don't want
to hit ctrl f7 you can actually bring up
this compile button you can do so by
right-clicking here and clicking on
build and then going out or remove
buttons customize and then adding a
command on the build called compile so
if we hit that button you can see that
we get our file compiling if we were to
make some kind of syntax error here for
example I'm forgetting a semicolon if I
compile that file you'll see that we get
an error
now Visual Studio presents us with
errors in many different ways one of
which is this error list and another way
is inside this output window I'm going
to tell you guys right now this error
list is mostly garbage it might appear
to be readable for really small things
like this but you never ever want to
rely on it a lot of times it's actually
missing information the weight of the
error lists work is it basically passes
our output window looking for the word
error and then grabs information from
there that it can find and puts it into
this error lit so it's it's a good
overview you want to use it like an
overview but if you want more details if
you want all the information about the
error that you've just had look at the
output window so for the rest of this
series I am actually going to be looking
at this output window for error messages
to get used to that you can see that
we've got an arrow here it says intact
arrow missing semicolon before a curly
bracket it tells you which line number
the error is on if you double click on
this actual line you will be taken to
where the error is in your source code
so let's go ahead and fix that
by adding a semicolon and then hitting
ctrl f7 or compile to build this one
file so we've compiled a file when you
compile files individually no linking
happens obviously you're just compiling
a single file so the linker is an
invoked apple let's go ahead and check
out what the compiler actually generated
if we right click on our hollow world
project you'll see an open folder in
File Explorer button this will open up
our File Explorer
by default visuals view will output our
build files into this debug folder and
you can see if we go in there you can
see a mean obj file this is the object
file that our compiler has generated
again you will have one of these for
every single simple file in your project
if we are back to visual studio and we
build the actual project so I'm doing
more than just building one file here
I'm actually building the entire project
you can see that we actually get that
exe file and again if we go back to our
file explorer that will actually be in
the directory of your solution and then
in the debug folder
I know visual Studios default paths are
a little bit weird I usually like to
change them but I'm trying to not to
complicate things here and there's our
hello world
exe file which we can run and it prints
the text hello world so that's a pretty
simple overview but what happens when we
have multiple people plus files let's
take a look at a simple example so
suppose that we've got our hollow world
printing the pecans all here but I don't
want to use the see out function I want
to use my own logging function and then
maybe that will wrap this see our
function so let's create a function
called log which will take in a C string
called message and print that message
choose a contour
simple enough now don't worry if you're
not sure what a Const char pointer is
we're going to talk about strings in
another video for now all you have to
know that a Const our pointer is
basically just a type that can hold a
string of text so now we can rewrite our
code so that instead of calling C out
and then printing hello world we call
this log function and then pass in
hollow world as a parameter we can go
ahead and hit the local windows debugger
button here just to make sure that it
still works as you can see it does
fantastic we've written our first
function that was easy so now let's take
that function and what it
into a different file because I don't
want to have this main does typically
files
flooded with all of my code I want to
separate my code into multiple files to
keep things nice and clean and organized
we'll make a new file under source files
like going a right-click add new item
we'll make a CPP file we'll call it log
build CPP and we'll click Add so what
I'm going to do here is I'm going to go
back to main and I'm going to cut this
log function and paste it into here so
now we've got a function inside our
logos with a file called log let's try
and compile just this file okay check
this out we get a bunch of errors and if
we look at our output window you'll see
that the out is not a member of STD
basically is telling us that it has no
idea what CL is the reason is because we
haven't included a declaration for the
out every kind of symbol in saqqaq lot
needs some kind of declaration the out
is defined inside a file that we
included in main dot cpp and that file
of course was iostream let's go ahead
and grab iostream and put it at the top
of this file so that we include iostream
by doing so we include a declaration for
this to be our function let's go ahead
and compile this file once again you can
see now it succeeds
great so back in main I want to call
this log function can I do that let's
hit ctrl f7 no I can't because log is
not found we also get a complaint about
the end but we already know that that's
because we removed the i/os trim
included and we have no idea what bian
is we can restore that include and our
problem should be fixed however you can
see that log is still not found so
what's going on here
we've moved a function from one file
into the other and we are compiling each
file separately for the minute so this
main dot CPP file has no idea that
there's a function called log somewhere
and since it doesn't recognize what log
is it gives us the compile error we can
fix this by providing something called a
declaration a declaration is exactly
what it sounds like we're declaring that
something called log exists now this is
almost like a promise because we can
just say hey compiler there's a function
called log however
the compiler will just believe us and
that's the great thing about the
compiler it'll be like oh yeah cool I
totally trust you because the compiler
doesn't care about resolving where that
log function actually is defined we have
two different words here declarations
and definitions declarations are just a
statement which say hey this symbol this
function exists and then a definition is
something that says this is what this
function is this is the body need for
this function so let's go ahead and
write a declaration for our log function
a declaration looks very similar to an
actual definition this is something
called a definition because you can see
that not only have we declared something
with the name logger function with the
name log we've also given it a body
which actually contains what code will
run when we call this function so back
in main let's write a declaration and a
declaration looks very similar to a
definition however what it doesn't have
is the actual body so you can see I can
just put a semicolon at the end of this
and that is the end of that in fact you
don't even have to specify the name of
the parameter because it doesn't matter
you can just write that and the rule of
thumb though I do like to specify the
name because it makes more sense so
let's compile this file now tallip check
this out the compiler totally bought it
so you might be wondering at this stage
what will hey how did the compiler know
that we actually have a log function in
another file if we're just compiling
this one file and the answer is it
doesn't it just it trusts us so then
your second question should be how does
it actually run the right code that is
where the linker comes in when we build
our entire project not just this one
file but if I actually right click and
hit build once our files have been
compiled the linker will actually find
the definition of that log function and
wire it up to the log function that we
call here in main dot CPP if it can't
find that definition that's when we get
a linker error now linking errors or
something
look very scary and a lot of people get
scared so let's go ahead and look at an
example of that so right now if I just
run my program you'll see that it still
prints out the text hello world and
everything runs successfully however
let's remove this or at least change it
a little bit for example I'll change
this to logger save the file go back
here to main Datsyuk B I'll try and
compile this file by itself you can see
that we get no problems whatsoever
however let's right-click on this hello
world and hit field and check this out
we get a pretty scary looking error
message which also and unfortunately
looks scary
in our output window now the reason this
looks those two carries because it's
actually got some extra information
about our functions ignition for example
it's got the pulling convention here as
well as an actual ID but basically what
it's telling you is that you have an
unresolved external symbol called log
which returns which has this return
value and these parameters and your
referencing this function inside main an
unresolved external symbol means that
the linker was unable to resolve a
symbol remembered linkers job is to
resolve symbols it has to wire up
functions and it couldn't find what to
wire log to because we don't have a
function called log that's actually
defined that has a body so the way that
we can fix this is by fixing our
function we need to provide a definition
for this log function in other words we
have to provide a body for this log
function doesn't have to be inside this
file it can be inside main but it has to
be somewhere and if we compile this
you'll see that we don't get any errors
if we go back to our file explorer and
look at what we've got inside our
intermediate folder here you'll see that
we've got two obj files because the
compiler generates an object file for
each of our CBP files the linker will
then take them and pitch them together
into an exe file so in our lovely
example we have our log definition
inside this log obj file
and our main function inside our main
door obj 12 and so link up will
basically take that log definition from
log and put it into a common binary
which is our hello world XP file which
contains a definition for both main and
log and that is a basic overview of how
C++ works again I highly encourage you
to check out the in-depth videos about
how compiling and linking works because
they're going to be way more information
than this video this video was just made
to show you kind of an overview of the
pipeline of how you go from source files
to an actual binary as always don't
forget to follow me on Twitter and
Instagram if you really enjoyed this
video and you want to see more you can
support me on patreon I'll see you guys
next time
goodbye war